I locked onto my computer this morning
and check my channel which is pretty
much a daily routine for me and saw that
I now have three thousand subscribers
which to me is an awesome milestone I
mean as cliche as it may sound I owe
this all to you a subscriber count to me
isn't simply a number that indicates how
good or popular your channel is it means
that roughly 3,000 people at least like
my content and found my channel worth
subbing too so thank you so much I swear
if if I could reach out into my screen I
would hug you all and we'd have a big
great group hug basically so um this is
the point where you guys come in I have
decided that I'm going to build a
coaster to celebrate this and you guys
can pick the theme and this can be
anything just don't go for anything
boring like medieval Arabian or whatever
no it can be anything you could choose
like a gabe newell's theme and
illuminati theme it might be like penis
theme know whatever basically whatever
you want I can be a TV show a fictional
character or an entire industry at
anything I'll build it and make sure
it's something awesome all you guys have
to do is leave a comment if you've got a
suggestion and give thumbs up to the
suggestions that you like and the one
that gets the biggest amount of the
thumbs up will be chosen as a theme for
the coaster and the one who did the
submission will receive a shout out or
something like that so that's that for
today and thanks again for everything
and I'll be looking forward to your
comments